ch traîner avant de commencer cette
émission vous m'avez dit si ça peut vous
faire plaisir ça peut faire plaisir à
aux autres invité au téléspectateurs je
bah je peux chanter une chanson si vous
voulez sur quoi non vousz pour une autre
émission d'arriver à la fin et alors je
vous ai dit dans celleen J'ai ni piano
ni band son nousavons rien nous alors
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire alors je
sais pas je peux je peux vous le dire
alors sans chanter si vous voulez dit
fait nous avons fait des livres qui sont
des des les souvenirs les souvenirs
auxquels nous sommes fidèles et bien
j'ai une chanson qui s'appelle fidèle et
qui se termine un petit peu pas par
hasard mais qui se termine un petit peu
sur quelque chose qui est un peu un peu
fatal aussi
et fidèle fidèle pourquoi rester fidèle
quand tout change et s'en va sans regret
quand on est seul debout sur la
passerelle devant tel ou tel monde qui
disparaît quand on rencontre tous les
bateaux qui sombrent en portant les
rêves qu'on espéré quand on s bien que
l'on n plus qu'une ombre fidèle à
d'autres ombres à
jamais très bien et et en chanson ça
faisait fidèle fidèle ah non non non non
non fidèle fidèle pourquoi rester fidèle
quand tout change et s'en va sans regret
quand on est seul debout sur la
passerelle devant tel ou tel monde qui
disparaî quand on regarde tous les
bateaux qui sombrent en portant les
choses qu'on espérait quand on sait bien
que l'on n plus qu'une ombre fidèle à
d'autres ombres à jamais alors il y a
l'orchestre
par
pas j'ai commencé par une chanson à la
il se pendait pour être
libre ex pas n à quoi bondir l'an
prochain quand on n'est pas du tout
certain d'être
ensemble oui oui après l'émission aès